Last lecture we solved the sequencetose
sequence bottleneck problem using the
cross attention mechanism where we built
an attention augmented RNN where the
encoder RNN here processes the source
sequence to build a memory bank H1 to
HT. The decoder RNN
generates the target sequence
step by step. For example, here we are
looking at the step T of the decoding
where this cross attention
lets the decoder query the encoder
memory to compute a dynamic context
vector CT. This solved the information
bottleneck and improved the quality of
translation
dramatically. models could handle longer
sequences and this approach became the
state-of-the-art from 2015 to 2017. But
as you see here, still the encoding
process is sequential. We cannot compute
HT until we have computed HT minus V.
This makes parallelization during
forward pass impossible. And for
sequences, it makes the training time
very long. And for sequences of size,
hundreds or thousands of tokens, the
training time will be very long. And
this sequential process means that uh we
are not really utilizing our GPUs. and
the GPUs are mostly sitting idle waiting
for this sequential computation to
complete. Why this is important? Because
if you remember the CNN architectures,
they are highly parallel and that's why
we could scale it to handle very large
data sets and that's what we want here
also to be able to scale the learning.
That's not possible here. As for example
in the encoder uh if we want to process
like let's say 100 uh token sequentially
we need 100 serial steps and if we want
to generate 80 tokens in the decoder we
need 80 serial step
which at total is
180 serial step per training example of
course
Um I mean you can think of parallelizing
on the batch size but a batch is of size
let's say 32 but our GPU has thousands
of cores that will that will be vastly
underutilized.
So I mentioned that CNN's are great for
I mean they are highly parallelizable
and they excel in image processing
because nearby pixels are highly
correlated.
uh in other words they have uh strong
local correlation
uh but we know that text is difference
and um the most critical relationship
can span long distances
so if we use a CNN for example for a
sentence like the dog chase its tail and
if we want to use let's say
local filters like this and we know that
eventually we can see all of this
relationship ship like this. For an
important relationship like dog and
tail, we have to go up let's say like
this to meet
and information must pass pass through
many layers and this degrades the signal
of course and we want to come up with a
different way of doing this encoding. So
the idea that uh around 2017 was well we
did the cross attention
and we came up with this general uh
attention formula that we discussed last
time. So in this uh attention mechanism
we get the queries from the decoder
uh or the query side keys and values
came from the encoder
or the memory bank. But of course
there's no requirement that Q K and V uh
come from different places. I mean they
can come from the same sequence.
for example the sequence X that we want
to encode.
So the sequence is in R and D
and we can form queries and keys and
values from the same sequence. What I
mean is basically Q is X WQ
and each X is asking what am I looking
for in my neighbors.
So X for example X2 here looks at all of
the neighbors and it's basically trying
to see if there is a neighbor or
neighbors that can improve its
representation
and add more context to it. Also the
same X provides keys and here he
basically means what
do I offer to others and at the same
time value?
What information do I contain?
So each position in the sequence can
attend to every other position to gather
context. Let's try this in a example. So
consider a sentence. Let's say
the bank by the river offers great views
of the boats.
And let's look at the bank position two
and let's assume it acts like a query.
What are my neighbors telling me about
my meaning? It looks at the river and
the key of river is basically unrelated
to water.
looks at offers and the keys I might be
a financial institution
and boats
um which the keys again I'm related to
water and the model computes attention
weights and there's a high attention to
river and boats and low attention to
offers let's say and it combines this
representations or values from these
neighbors to basically add context to
its meaning. So it realizes that oh this
is a river bank not a financial bank and
it's crucial to note that this all
happens within this sentence itself.
Each word refineses its presentation by
attending to related words. So that's
how we update the embedding of each of
these words or tokens and uh we can
encode them and when we want to do the
decoding in an auto reggressive way
we're looking at the previous so let's
say we have a word here that we want to
predict we look at the all previous
words and query them to update it uh the
meaning of that or predict that uh note
that during the training we may have the
future tokens also which we have to mask
uh to not let the model cheat by
querying them. So this is called causal
masking which we will see in the code.
Okay. So with that let's go uh back to
this scale.
uh attention and just review that one
more time and then uh using that we can
reddesign this encoder decoder
architecture with self attention and
cross attention fully and we drop we
want to drop anything else that is for
example uh related to RNN or CNN. So
again given a input sequence X
and this is in R let's say N by D
each sequence has n tokens and each
token has a D dimension. So this uh
dimension here is important somehow
tells us what is the dimension of the
representation for each one of these
tokens
and uh we call this the model. We will
project them to this q k and v spaces.
So q is x wq which
projects x to this query space.
Same for keys and values.
So note that uh the Q space Q and K are
in the same size because they want to
look for their similarity but the value
space is not necessarily at the same
dimension. So that's why we call it DV.
That means that WQ and W K have the have
similar dimension of D model
by DK.
WV has dimension of D model DV. Then we
compute the attention scores
using this scale dotproduct
which is a square matrix.
And the entry I of I and J of this
matrix measures how much position I
should attend to position J.
And then we apply the soft max. So if
this is step one, two, three, here we
apply softmax to get attention weights
which is the same size and each row sums
to one uh giving a probability
distribution over positions to attend
to. And that basically led us to the
weighted combination of all of these
values or the output that we are looking
for which is attention weights multiply
by V.
So given that what's the self attention
of X? It's basically soft max of the
dotproduct of X WQ
and X W K. Here we have a transpose and
then X WV.
Okay. So let's look closely at this
um few observation. We don't care about
u the order. Everything attends to
everything. So even if we shuffle the
input, the output shuffles in the same
way, right? So this is permutation
equivariant.
The entire computation is parallel,
right? And all positions can compute
their attention simultaneously.
Uh this is all to all connection. every
position can directly attend to every
other position in one step. So, uh none
of those matrices wk
and w
depend on the sequence lengths. That
means that the same wq wk and wv works
for any n.
Okay, which is very significant.
Okay, so the there are some nice
computation aspects, right? But there is
a problem here and
the problem is where did the sequence
order go? Previously we had uh
RNN and order was inherent right here
self attention is basically a bag of
vectors for example let's say what's the
output
I the attention output for position I
and that's basically the sum and we know
that sum doesn't care it's just a
weighted sum and it's permutation
invariant
so it's a back of vectors basically
We lost the notion of order.
That means that a sentence like the cat
chase the mouse for self attention is
the same as the mouse
chased the cat. That means that the self
attention basically produce identical
representation for both sequences.
But these sentences have opposite
meanings.
So we must explicitly provide positional
information here. There are different
ways of doing it and we will uh zoom
into this positional encoding uh later
but for now let's just
say that the input to self attention so
far was token embedding.
Right? we have to update this with some
positional encoding and this will be the
input for self attention.
So basically positional encoding will be
a vector of the same dimension as the
token embedding and it basically infuses
the position to the embedding. But for
now let's assume we're not really
learning this and we can basically give
this in a deterministic way and given
that we know the relative uh position
between words and the encoder will
consider that in the update of the
embeddings. Okay. So with that we know
how to do self attention.
Now let's design our encoder decoder
architecture with this. So no more RNN
we want to do everything with attention.
So self attention within the sequence
and cross attention between the encoded
encoded and decoded sequences.
Okay. So let's rewrite this. We have the
input X here the embedding of X and then
we are
adding the positional encoding and now
this is the new
representation for each tokens. So now
we want to do self attention from the
same X here.
Let's call this X.
we have Q, K and V. So each sequence
attends to itself. Okay. And then like
we discussed before in the previous
lecture, we need some form of
nonlinearity. So the nonlinearity
basically helps us to get these rich
functions that allow for these linear
spaces to work. We need a feed forward
neural network. That's the output of
this attention layer. This is one
attention layer. So we can of course
repeat and stack several of these layers
uh stacking n times of them. And at the
end we will have keys and value pairs
that is the output of this encoder.
Okay. So now we want to use this to
decode or generate new sentences or
sequences. Let's just repeat the same
thing. Just copy this. So now the output
follow the same thing the here we have
output embedding and again positional
encoding and then again self attention
within this decoder sequence but we want
this decoder to talk to the encoder
state right so before sending it to the
feed forward nor network we will add
another attention but this time a cross
attention like what we did before we
allow this decoder sequence to query the
encoder. So like I said this is
basically a cross attention and then the
output of this guy goes to the feed for
a noral network and that's basically an
decoder attention layer and we can have
another bunch of this layers stacking on
each other. Okay. And then we can send
this updated representation to uh let's
say a linear neural network and a
softmax. So the linear gives us the
logits, the softmax gives us the
probabilities and this basically is the
output
probabilities which we sample from and
we get the next token and we repeat
this. Okay. And that's the auto
reggression way of decoding. There are
of course some architectural trick to
make this stable and make sure it's
learning. For example, if we want to
stick with the original paper by Vasan
Vwani at all. They added skip connection
to all of these blocks to make sure we
have this residual highways and then a
form of normalization that makes sure
the variance is controlled. So let's add
the skip connections. We have one here
and one here. Same on the other side.
And as you remember in CNN, it's always
good to do normalization to make sure
things are scaled and there is no
coariance shifts for example. And to do
that here we're using layer
normalization.
And to do that here the original
transformer paper proposed layer
normalization in this form that I'm
going to write here.
So here here is the normalization and as
you see it basically makes sure the
signal that we are sending upward is
always
stable and scaled and of course the skip
connections or the residual are making
our gradients reachable to the deeper
states.
Okay. So let's again review. We have
this input embedding. We add the
positional encoding. We have this
encoder self attention which each
position attends to all positions in the
input. And then we have the decoder
which is masked self attention meaning
that each position attends only to
previous positions. This is the causal
masking that I mentioned. Of course we
have this cross attention uh where the
decoder attends to encoder outputs. Same
as last lecture, we have this feed
forward neural networks that provides
this expressiveness that we want. It
also acts like a learned feature map
that we discussed in the kernel
discussion from last time. Most of the
parameters uh are in this uh feed
forward neural networks. So looking at
them and uh it's good to zoom in into
this uh sub layers and discuss the
importance of them and why they are
carrying the most number of parameters
and we expect the and we expect them to
carry most of the expressiveness of the
neural network. So basically the self
attention part it mixes the content and
fit for a neural network provides this
nonlinear transformations and why they
provide this uh kind of separation of
concern for us.
So let's think of these transformers
like a like a librarian. I mean after
all
large language models are following this
transformer architectures
and somehow we have this impression that
they are memorizing the internet. Of
course, it's a lossy compression, but
it's a very very efficient compression.
And that's why let's make this analogy.
And it's like we can think of
transformers like a library that reads
and summarizes
and organizes the the library and it
comes up with this efficient shelving.
Basically, the embedding space. It
organizes the summaries by placing
similar concepts next to each other. So
again this organizational system is the
model's highdimensional vector space
that it learns via this gradient descent
and then there is a knowledge store
which like I said requires the most
number of parameters and that's mostly
carried by the feed forward neural
networks. So you can think of this feed
forward neural networks like like memory
also. So they are like the specialized
bookshelves where the compressed
knowledge is stored. When we provide a
prompt or a query, we're asking this
librarian a question. And the attention
mechanism acts like an efficient search
that allows the librarian to instantly
identifies the relevant sections because
the library is organized by similarity
and compares the query or the request
against the keys or the indices let's
say to find relevant concepts. So
attention decides where to look and once
the attention gathered the relevant
context the feed for a neural networks
accessing the specific knowledge or the
values associated with the context to
determine the next word for example here
in LLMs. So the FFNS or the field for
neural networks decides what information
to apply. So we can think of it like
attention is basically performing
contentbased routing or mixing across
all tokens
which is like the librarian is finding
the right aisles and the feed for neural
networks perform this token local
computation
that acts like a dense associative
memory
which is like the content on the
shelves.
So even if you look at then FFN
so let's write it like this a two layer
FFN is like this right it so looking at
this component wise let's assume we can
rewrite this in a summation form
J through F. So let's look at the one
row of this computation. So one J which
is J row of W W W W W W W W W W W W W W
W W W W W W W W W W W W W W W W W W W W
W W W W W W W 1 plus B1 J. So this is a
row. It means that when it's when it's
negative, it gives zero. So this is only
positive or zero multiply by VJ. So VJ
is the J column of W2. So let me write
this out. J column W2
and this is J row
W1.
So let's zoom into this. Uh this part is
basically deciding if the neuron is
activated or not
corresponds to the first layer. Right?
If it is activated
a value VJ will be returned to the token
string which corresponds to the W2. So
you can think of it like uh this is like
a key and this is like a value right
just like what we did previously with
kernel regression. So you can think of a
dense fit for neural network as a large
bank of key and value pairs
softly selected by an input context.
In other words, it's like really like a
mixture of expert where an expert is
invoked and the opinion will be seek. So
during the training these W1JS
push to activate the specific contextual
patterns
and the VJS or the values
point toward directions that raise the
correct next token logits.
So we can think of this
pairs of W1,
J and VJS
as storing the association
for context and next token.
Many such pairs superpose and yielding a
sparse distributed memory. Remember that
this also does interpolation between
what it observe in the data. So the
interpolation comes from the fact that
this gate here varies smoothly with X.
In mathematical language we basically
say ReLU is lip sheets and this makes
nearby context activating similar
neurons. So it's like a peacewise linear
kernel smoother really. Great. So that's
the interplay between the attention and
the fit for normal networks. Here the
last point before moving on when we look
at the attention head it basically
computes the output as a weighted
average of the value vectors across all
positions. This averaging mechanism can
dilute information
and somehow prevent the models to focus
sharply on different aspects of the
sequence at the same time. For example,
in language we have different
relationship like for example semantic
roles and positional context and so on.
And if we want to compress all of them
into one weighted sum, it reduces the
effective resolution. So to counteract
um this reduction in resolution, we use
multiple attention head. So we have
several of them. And looking at the
figure two of the original paper here,
for example, we have each attention
head. Each attention head gets a subset
of the embedding space. Right? So for
example, if the embedding space is DV,
we chop it into H and each attention
head attends to one of the
representation subspace. So at the end
all of these outputs of this attention
heads will be concatenated to obtain the
updated QV.
uh we can discuss the details of
positional encoding and the
normalization.
Let's discuss the positional encoding in
transformers and first we list a bunch
of properties that we like an positional
encoding scheme to satisfy. We like each
position to have a distinct
representation. So a uniqueness
property. Ideally we want the encoding
to be reproducible and not random. So
determinism
um we want this to have a bounded range.
We don't want to uh mess up with the
embedding that we are updating during
the transformer layers. So bounded range
and it should work for sequences longer
than those we see during training. So
generalizable the encoding must
distinguish between near and far
positions. at different scales, right?
So somehow multiscale uh distance
awareness,
we don't want to mess up with the
continuity for gradient descent. So the
nearby positions should have similar
encoding. So some kind of smooth
transition. Also uh since we are dealing
with linear transformation in the
embedding space any shifting position
let's say from i to i + delta should
correspond to a simple linear
transformation for example a rotation.
about linear transor
mobility.
Okay. So let's uh start from the
simplest ideas and build toward
a scheme that satisfy all of these
properties. So let's assume a sequence
of size of length n.
Um one simple encoding is to basically
assign each position a normalized scalar
value between zero and one. Right? So
basically from zero to one. So the
positional encoding will take a form
like this. And then we can update the
the embedding of input
let's say at position i with ei + p i.
And since we want this to be a vector of
size um dimension, this should be a one
vector. Okay, which is in dimension.
Okay, so let's look at this simple
encoding. So one issue here is this
linear transformability. If you look at
this, all of this encodings are this
parallel vectors of direction one. So
they are all point in the same direction
and they only differ in magnitude. So if
you write the score between let's say EI
and EJ this will be like u adding the
same global bias to everything. In other
words if you have let's say a
two-dimensional embedding let's say the
embedding of cat is here the embedding
of sat is here the embedding of Matt is
here.
This positional encoding will add just a
vector like that and there's not really
a distinguishing geometric structure. So
what we can learn from here? First we
need a multi-dimensional structure. This
is not multi-dimensional. We need a rich
geometric interaction.
So we need some form of meaningful
geometric relationship after this
updates. And we need some form of
directional
divers diversity. So different positions
should point in different direction not
the same direction. So let's do another
attempt
and for that we will bring uh from our
previous knowledge and we want to
represent each position using this
binary uh coding. So again this is the
axis of position let's say 0 to I don't
know like 0 to 7 and um we want to
represent this with different beats
right for example
so we can go on and on but basically the
idea here is we have the finest scale
here we have a medium scale here and we
have a coarse scale here with different
periods.
So this is this looks much better. Each
bit provides a different level of
positional information. We can
distinguish nearby positions. We can
also distinguish distant position. So
previously if you remember previously it
was easy to distinguish distant relation
but not nearby relation. Okay. But here
that's not the case. we can basically uh
compare nearby relationships with the uh
higher frequency and the distant
relationships with lower frequency.
So this works in terms of being
multiscale uh different dimension
captures different granularities of
position. It is unique. Um it allows for
easy distinguishing between local let's
say here for example one and two and
global 1 and 7 by using different
periods and different scales. However
the the main issue here is it's not
smooth and we want really we want to
deal with continuous functions and sharp
discontinuities
makes our optimization very difficult.
So let's make it smooth instead of bits
we will work with waves and the natural
choice here for this oscillating
functions are s and cosine waves. Okay.
So basically instead of this we have
like slow period or faster period or an
even faster periods. These are bonded
and but the nicest thing about this uh s
and cosine pairs is um it is compatible
with rotation and the rotation is
naturally expressed using s and cosine.
For example, rotation in 2D with a teta
angle can be written like this. That's a
rotation. And in the case of positional
encoding using this sign and cosine, the
positional encoding between two words
like word one and word two with a
distance delta corresponds to a rotation
of delta. Now uh of course the choice of
the frequency depends on the length of
this dimension. Okay. So with this let's
build the calculate formula. So for
position I and dimension J, we are
asking for a sign or a cosine. So
depending if it's an uh odd dimension or
an even dimension. So let's say 2 J or 2
J + one. The formula for this guy is a
sinus of I position I but with this
frequencies.
For the odd position we have cosine I
same frequency. So if we want to plot
this this is basically like faster
frequencies. When you go down you have
slower frequencies. Again it's easy to
distinguish between long distances and
small distances using this balance of
scales. And this pairs of s and cosine
help us to interpret this distances like
rotation in this embedding space. So if
you look at the h position. So looking
at this will look like something like
this. And if we want to
relate this to this very common figure,
it's basically
faster frequencies here
then slowing down
here. For example, this is just some a
deep like this
and slower and slower. Okay. Um
so this is the default. This is the
first positional encoding that was
proposed by uh the original transformer
paper. But there are many other
positional encodings. There are even
learnable positional encodings that can
be useful for some specific
applications. Let's say like time series
analysis. And um I encourage you to play
with different types of positional
encoding.